hi there steve kaufman here um i want to
do a little
a little video here in praise of the
the beginner books the starter books
that we
certainly that i
often go to when i'm starting in a
language
and
and i've just been reviewing for my
russian i've been reviewing you know
there's an expression in french
we always go back to our first loves
and when i started russian i started
with this book here
which is the teach yourself russian book
and now after four years i'm going
through it again and it's not the second
time that i'm going through it i've gone
through it many times
and i think these little starter books
are tremendous value and i particularly
am fond of the teach yourself series but
i also use colloquial
um i guess those are my two favorites
and and i think the good starter books
are small
okay i think that's the
first the major
you know quality that i look for in a
starter because i know that i'm gonna
have to go through it many times and the
third fourth fifth sixth time i go
through it i wanna be able to go through
quickly
so i like them when they're small
the the second thing
about these starter books is
that really everything you need
in order to speak the language
comfortably
is is in this first little book
that's the amazing thing
however
it's impossible to retain
everything that's in this book not on
the first pass not on the second pass
not on the third pass because you just
at least for me i just don't have enough
connection to the language experience
with the language to be able to retain
all the good stuff that's here and
that's why i have to keep on going back
and going back and going back and every
time i go back i pick up a little
something
extra
uh
i like the teach yourself book because
as i remember because i haven't been
listening to it again but there's no
english on the recording which is very
important i hate listening to english i
hate when they tell me in english what
i'm about to hear in russian or in
whatever language
i just want the language it's got the
the words are translated in here any
explanations i need are in this little
book
the rest of it i just want to hear it
uh i should also confess that i don't
like the pimsleur approach i don't like
the approach where we're asked to say
something like in pimpster they ask you
a question you have to answer i don't
want to do that some people like doing
it i don't
i totally ignore
any questions or drills that are in this
book all i do mostly
is read the little dialogue
read the vocabulary list skim through
the the grammatical explanations just so
that i can get through the dialogue
really
because i have found that any attempt to
try and remember the rules or try to
remember the endings it's just an
exercise in frustration you learn it you
you think you learn it you spend some
time at it and you very very
quickly forget it
the other thing about these beginner
books is they are very important to get
started
even if you were able and i don't
certainly i'm not able to retain
everything that's in this book
even after the first second third time
but
the other thing is of course you need a
lot of words
so there's only a limited number of
words in here you know if you end up at
the end of this book with
500 words or a thousand words
i mean you need 30 40 000 words in
russian in my opinion because
where i end up is is any kind in any
conversation or anything i'm listening
to or anything i want to say
it's the words that i don't have if i
have the words but i use the wrong
ending or the wrong tense it's okay
people can figure out what i'm saying
but if i don't have the words you know i
can't communicate so the starter books
are great they get you started it's that
those as i read through it now i can
still hear those dialogues because i
listen to them so often i can hear them
and and as i read through them now then
i find that i'm i'm sort of
reinforcing things about the language
that i have learned
uh
or things about the structure that i
have learned through experience through
reading the rules 10 times and stuff and
i see it reinforced and somehow rather
it helps and the other thing is no
matter how advanced you think you are
and i listen daily to you know
sophisticated political discussions in
russian and i understand essentially 99
of what's said
uh there are always little things in the
beginner book that you're missing and
you go back in there and it just helps
to fill in the cracks so i love the
little beginner books i go back to them
often even after four years i go back to
them and i get a lot of enjoyment out of
doing it so i just wanted to say here's
to the good beginner books and i think
the teach yourself series is a
particularly good series
and
now you might say well why am i
promoting teach yourself i should be
promoting link which i'm always happy to
do but people who come to link
particularly if they're at the beginning
of their you know learning experience in
the language we always i always
recommend get yourself a little book i
mean
even people who buy teach yourself
they're going to do other things you
know the language learning experience
you've got to go out there looking for
resources all the time there is no one
solution for all i think link is a big
part of the picture but i think these
beginner books like teach yourself are
also a very important part of the
picture
thank you for listening